figure out who you are don't apologize
for who you are and then become even
greater than you naturally are at what
you are
[Music]
you
[Music]
I know something on the I know I got
superpowers but that's something on the
I know what I want is behind a fan and
my high boss that form on my website
that goes to the Simone the biggest
thing that I want from this salesperson
is not to do new business for
vaynermedia the way you and I think
about it it's to turn the 400 to 900
requests a week we get that really want
some version of me they don't even know
what they want and to into something
it's time to create a CRM of everybody
who asked me for something convert them
into something for myself later media
for the Vayner family of millions of
characters and then click IDO not yet do
I got the time now she's naked dream but
that's not even oh my god loved octopus
that thing keep running now to rise I
love it well listen I'm going to I'm
going to talk to my brother and see if
we can see if we can figure something
out that's cool fun and interesting and
worthwhile for everybody my pleasure
time great day I'm gonna so like I will
keep at it
I will there's one [ __ ] thing I can
guarantee everybody right now let's go
jet
that always keeps poking at we close one
damn good keeper being a thug stay in a
vise in a vise and a final squat I got a
lot of Statham down it bad man oh yeah
what were my golf hey hello how are you
good I'm Gary Vaynerchuk yep
have you been a great healthy the
podcast and going how many how many Jim
clearly it's so funny I actually think
my cancer they had a harder time being
successful than I was I think being born
in Belarus coming here with nothing my
parents working every minute that
instilled a huge competitive advantage a
chip on my shoulder a work ethic that I
you know I think was a very big reason
that in the American meritocracy system
to the you know my comparison I there's
always stuff but in capitalism only
version that we've listed in the last 58
years in America immigrants win a lot I
was a very poor student which was really
unusual for immigrants but but I don't
see education as my way out I knew that
I had it and that originally started as
I'm a good salesman and then I'm a good
businessman and then it was I'm a good
operator and now the current term is I'm
a great entrepreneur so yeah it's a DNA
thing with me even online dating I'm not
always on JD's right in 2003 when it was
granted right and when it was super like
Sakura theses no it was Korea New York
Jewish stating skaters pretty happened
but I just remember thinking like in ten
years every single person
I didn't think I'd be swiping to the
right but like I'm like every person's
going to do this because this is
practical and so people romantic people
like well I would never buy a tomato on
the internet this is what I heard in 96
I like see well because time is valuable
because other things matter more and so
I knew because I thought people need
buying stuff on the internet long before
a lot of people thought what is dinner
like with Mark Zuckerberg
well if visit two thousand eight nine
ten that's the mark I know I knew it
like when I tell you I knew it I wish it
was video blogging back then the first
Center I it was so interesting to me so
I'm built on emotional intelligence I'm
not the smartest I just know what people
going to do so he's a tech kid and an
engineer and Harvard kid so I go in
thinking he's back I read that dinner on
my clock this kid absolutely gets human
behavior so that's when I knew by
narrowly that he was going to win it so
much well he's got both he knows how to
build it like I can't build stuff I'm
not an engineer and it's not what I'm
into I'm like if he understands what I
understand was it I mean I was just
brought into him from day one he's super
smart enough listen we're a funny match
in a 10 or 15 times we've interacted
because I only want to talk and he only
wants to listen so I hotel ended with a
hell of a lot more money and be
successful but he's extremely bright I
like him a lot I think he's kind but
most of all he just understands people
and that's weird because people look at
him as like introverted and quirky and
all that but I don't say it and I never
saw and then obviously who are media
trained and grown into himself so I
can't speak to how he rolls out cuz I
don't spend time with him but I can
definitely tell you there was no
confusion from from that from those
initial meetings for me and I mean none
how do you get rid of friends who are
useless to you it's not you know that's
not funny it's not useless right it
isn't the one that I've been very hard
on talking about in the world but it is
scared of because anything you just said
that I got so terrible it is I think
that people are keeping very negative
people around them and if they aspire to
change their situation it's imperative
to audit the 7 to 10 people that are
around you and the reason I go after a
friend or
apparently not in the details of that
headline I said hey you may have to do
audit your mom and that's what I want
you to never talk to your mom again but
you may want to take a step back and
I've done this for friends and
acquaintances and it's a very painful i
opening experience to realize wait a
minute
my dad actually doesn't want me to be
successful because he's not happy and
you know whether they call misery loves
coming in and it's not like parents are
bad people it's a human trait it's just
a thing so to me in a world where it's
much harder to get rid of your older
sister forever
it might be intriguing to say hey I've
had this friend who spends all their
time making sure I'm not going to the
next level and really came around the
fact that who listens to you the group
when you complain he only puts the
people that will listen to you are the
people that happened your poor family
and your other loser friends right like
other people who also want to complain
about their boss and yeah I thought it
was actually a very good emotional not
willing to be talked about non
politically correct thing to say maybe
if you got rid of one friend or spent a
lot less time with one friend who's a
real drag and a negative force and added
a positive person in your office as
somebody you know if you switch it from
eightydaze hang out with your negative
friend and one day with your office
acquaintance she's super positive to
four days with your negative friend and
12 with a super sense not only do I
believe I've basically watched me mentor
people in my organizations to a totally
different life on that thesis listen I
don't hide from being an extrovert it
comes naturally I can't contain it I
actually think there's plenty of
negatives that go along with like being
out there but I think whether you know
see a lot of people come to me
introverts hey Gary I'm gonna be like
you I want to be out there like why and
then I thought aha
you're crushing it easy more you not a
little bit of me self-awareness I need
to run and I will do this again I
promise
self-awareness and then reverse engineer
and put yourself in the position to
succeed
let's go just release ah you go remember
me you say what's your name again Friday
don't call it it alright are we talking
about are you my pleasure I mean you got
a good sales pitch it's only for our
four minutes I just can't explain to
everybody like clearer when you figure
out who you are and do all that you win
if you're great a painting pink and hire
a partner to be your salesperson
if somebody at 20 years old made me
their business partner as a painter
maybe the most famous painter in the
world yet most painters want to be the
salesmen and businessmen and women as
well as the painter and there's a
problem
85% of painting 90% of people that are
greater painting are artists and don't
have the DNA to sell and my first up all
my sales friends and business friends
that want to start all these businesses
around something creative I've got news
for you Joel you know you can be a great
salesman but your pottery suck [ __ ] and
so that's that so like and it's really
that's a very funny analogy for the
following figure out who you are don't
apologize for who you are and then
become even greater than you naturally
are at what you are that's the whole the
whole the whole game is broken because
everybody's too tied up into other
people's opinions I only care about my
opinion myself and I care what my mom
and wife and kids and the world think
just not as much as I care about the way
I think about myself and I and that's it
just that slight advantage and I think
most of you care more about what other
people think and what you think about
yourself
and or you actually don't feel good
about yourself right the thing that made
me smile when you just introduced me you
said I'm one of the most motivational
people in the world , and everybody I
know that's met them studies the nicest
there's no comparison to the better
feeling of people and have actually
gotten to know me say that versus
millions hundreds of thousands tens of
thousands thinking on the coolest and
and and that's it I mean that's it and
that's why and that's why it's easy for
me to feel good about myself
right and so I think a lot of people
need to start with themselves maybe the
reason they don't have more confidence
in themselves or care about their
opinion about themselves versus others
is because they know they're doing
things they don't like so they need to
work on that I get offered and emailed
five thousand different requests for
podcasts and shows and what's what I
think my friend here on let's use name
Evan bow-bow let's sing it in bow I'm
sorry Evan Carmichael introduced me to
bow the bows figure out is time of the
asset and so if you want Kevin harder
the rock or or Beyonce or job rule or
Richard Branson or Tony shine or Sheryl
Sandberg on your podcast maybe you
should start the hundred twenty second
podcast and then you got to be creative
in trying to figure out how you get
maybe you create the one question video
show is it no shows one question
promised you a lot of people that you
want is guess if they see in the
headline
I just need four minutes of your time
for the one question show a lot more
gonna say yes then can you be on my
podcast for now would have what's going
on with the [ __ ] dragon yeah sure Hey
look the happy Raptors not too happy now
I remember when I used to laugh a lot
nowadays not only lol blue text Kazan
wanted talks don't touch me I don't want
to feel we wrote this verse a couple
times first time I kept away to real
that before drop and keep it real you
really drop me on my
and now we blazing something right we're
live fish fish all right how are you in
the group thank you how are ya
such a pleasure see you thought
traditional television producer and I'm
dying to get into digital I feel like
it's time to shake it up go for
something I don't really know kind of
ready to take the risk appointment I'm
so happening in the world happening yeah
I was wondering if you look at my resume
or haven't talked it through don't give
me one more audio-in oh man so context
it up for the Hulu and Amazon and
Netflix are the preview there'll be more
players I mean I want me to be on
Apple's one of Apple's new original
shows like there's a lot going on I
actually think this is very similar to
publishing remember like eight nine
years ago everyone if I'm a newspaper
journalist I'm dead yeah you're not dead
you're just going to work at different
places right so I think I think you
could fit anywhere I think the bigger
thing that I can help you with is not
necessarily anything other than four to
five to seven people to meet yeah that
can give you the speeding up I mean I
think the one thing you'll have to kind
of wrap your head around is I don't know
how fluffy or comfortable the budgets of
the traditional TV where all the work or
are or the people you work with
I think that's usually the biggest thing
that people struggle with when there's a
landscape change is that usually when
there's a big landscape change which is
absolutely gonna happen with television
yeah you're coming from the end of an
era which means it's the fattest and and
kind of like most manifested of the
overhead that it takes to do it and then
you go into the new world and then a new
world becomes the old world right you
know cable when it was first produced
with right you know let me give you a
really good piece of ice if you are not
on snapchat you should get on it and you
should you're not I'm not good let me
show you something that I want you to
that's very important to the tool to the
15-year part of your career maybe not
tomorrow but
thirty-six months this world is very
real which is not that understanding
such as the heart of fire closer than a
foot are you going to Google you very
well how do I use snapchat yeah you're
going to download it and in the day
you'll get it yeah there's a part cook
where they call discovery whether their
media is done in here you have to see
how bizarre is producing like you have
to see what's happening both in video
and audio form because this is where the
world is going like you have to
understand this if you don't you're
basically making radio content
Preda television right thanks such a
pleasure yeah have a great day to dinner
don't try to keep me now you can start
with event a couple months ago [ __ ]
what's hard for us to be friends
your heart is so much bigger ever since
I made a big mistake this really how to
maximize your time here but if they're
together
good afternoon how are you good good to
see you like I already nobody say big
day big day for us on remember me you
say what's your name again fine you know
you can you get all comedies alright
yeah are we talking about what why are
you able to get these new episode so
quick and d-roc take so long
could be a quality thing maybe he rocks
are really good and yours like mailed in
beautiful your passport like that I take
a photo that's real to prove Who I am or
whatever yes would be three just how
they get to verify got it look I get
trying to get you very well thank you
very cool claiming I get a nice
I sent you and Tommy now yep you win but
you were upset somebody else is Ram
happy nothing ahead of you so initially
it was not really going to be related to
me yeah I know others others noisy
I'm ready go but I was speaking in
Toronto in a conference and went to Q&A
and Jerome raised his hand and said if
I'd be human Rock Paper Scissors can I
come to New York and have coffee with
you and I said sure came on stage he
beat me in rock-paper-scissors
I met him in New York a couple months
later he comes to New York for ten
minutes coffee I was hoping to get out
of there of e two minutes two hours
later I'm asking two rows to come with
me to Los Angeles two days later to
start sometimes me what ended up
happening is Jerome start talking about
what we believe is happening online and
with vying influencers I had lived
through that with YouTube and Twitter I
believed him and we decided literally
that like to start a partnership around
this amazing world of influencers online
and for the story that yes what kind of
homeless the house in New York and
deeper that in fact to eat unity makes
you very quickly he met me right away
but to his credit was very hard he lived
in we literally slept in our office you
know our business didn't have any money
and he wasn't making money from the
brand so your own struggle was real yes
he met me and yes I had a business and I
like I could have paint in war but he
wanted to own on his own merit and we
were building a business together so he
kept it very humble and he he dried it
and there was many nights that people
would lean on me and say there's a man
sleeping in our office Oh soldier really
really for New York City at vaynermedia
headquarters
fifteen pounds here were advertising
agency that focuses on social media
questions
really yeah yeah what's the deal why you
think I stay down my scale well just let
me show you around thirty days until
your baby fell 30 minutes a penny or two
goes right by the guy yo D I'm gonna
take it with the plan they just want to
laugh when ta how do you have the [ __ ]
cover me I know it's a bit
I don't think goodness here smell good
luck
[ __ ] it old friends buzz life is good
man business I am uh I don't know you
tell me
grab one kgs fans believe it Amy
Janet Zaman taken teams to reduce power
to our girl gotta coast team Sam more
shows and a multi-speed really be very
friend it probably ends up being a huge
win I'm committed to whatever takes to
make everybody feel delicious on your
end that's number one
and then then number two it will then
source a conversation on two fronts
one getting us a line of some of these
things on a Facebook world where all the
action is there's so much good happening
but it also then leads into like
optimizing creative which is something I
want to do a little bit more of so we'll
open up that can of worms as well yes I
understand quote alright I'm really
behind it I'll start digging even
further and then up levity I'll give you
any updates along the way before the
summit okay okay talk it by on routes
and glory
[Music]
I mean people girl if I should I feel
sorry but I was fascinated so
misunderstood but it's all good
enjoy my view from Hollywood that's what
they call me it's all good I'm Hollywood
yep yep yep
in John you you inset you using a video
and then there's somebody over here
you're watching and over here and goes
if you see this and go to this URL will
give you what does he gave away a
thousand something but only the people
that moved and saw the information
because then the press picks then
everybody goes no no you have to turn to
get then people will start understanding
the game that's what you need you need a
piece of content that not only brings
enormous awareness that gave the leader
but teaches people what to do I got it
covered up ok uh I want to do another
wine dinner ASAP
let me did the other day yeah you know
how we did eight people and there's two
people I want I want him and I want
Jacqueline Susann my can you email both
of them and see if they're around in
three to four weeks pick a day cancel
something because I feel like I'm locked
in pretty hard so give me some options
and let's do another one
I'm starting to do these little wine
dinners introducing friends you just
came here Hoboken well I keep it really
and I don't think I'll ever changed
I'm they have a life you can look me in
the face I swear the guy that we [ __ ] is
in the amount things I'll never change I
keep it real
Ram and Megan yes yeah thank you yeah
yeah we made it look like thank you
better get it
it's or short kalanjiam for a pod yeah
yeah let me do this um dynamically
syphilis there
look what are give you one massively
good piece of ice I will always say no
when I'm being told to do something
always always it's like how nice how do
you not pick up like you picked up on
every single thing except low
what's that yes we only get day one so
[ __ ] you if you hate me but a work at
[ __ ] is day two in a rich [ __ ] is
day three going to [ __ ] on my own no
what the hell can you change me call
Harvey's no cloned you couldn't see me
wet eight you would a telescope with a
microscope [ __ ] in the dark with a lot
of phones or mobile wrappers and smoke
weed with white girl to get Emma Stone
I'm not saying they're weak I'm just
saying that they're not me
so don't know I was that right yeah
that's a trap but I keep it really and I
don't think I'll ever change
I'm they have a life you can look me in
the face
I swear to God that we [ __ ] is in there
my thanks I'll never change I'll keep it
real
real man mega Serbia